salud en directo américa de france 24 y
ya está conmigo el estudio más o menos a
la mar hablemos de cover vacuna nueva
vacuna contra el cohetes y una vez
diseñada en eeuu pero libre de patentes
y una buena noticia mar en medio de todo
no es una buena noticia exactamente
sobre todo por esa parte de la libertad
de las patentes de que esa información
va a estar disponible para todo el mundo
recordemos que es una vacuna que ha sido
diseñada por el hospital infantil de
texas y la escuela baylor de medicina
cor bbva que son dos instituciones
privadas con carácter sede sin ánimo de
lucro en houston en estados unidos por
ahora los únicos resultados que tenemos
sobre su eficacia son los publicados por
el mismo hospital infantil de texto de
texas eso nos lleva a tener que hacer
todavía un poco prudentes con estas
cifras pero por ahora lo preliminar es
que tiene un 90 por ciento de eficacia
para prevenir la enfermedad contra la
variante original del virus del cob y 19
y un 80% contra la variante delta además
los anticuerpos según dice este mismo
estudio descienden sólo un 30% después
de seis meses de la de la segunda
vacunación de nuevo importante recordar
que todavía en sonda que no han sido
publicado raúl en una revista médica le
pregunto como entonces han influido las
patentes en esta lucha contra la
pandemia de kobe 19 porque tan
importante claro de hecho ya hay muchas
voces que reclaman que las farmacéuticas
liberen estas patentes porque eso haría
que fueran mucho más accesibles para
todos estos países que no están pudiendo
vacunar a su población y cerrar un poco
esta brecha tan desigual que existe en
la inmunización global en cambio hay
muchísimas otras voces por ejemplo las
de las farmacéuticas o las de los países
de algunos países del norte global que
siguen defendiendo que estas patentes
deben mantenerse repasemos como han sido
los beneficios de estas grandes
farmacéuticas gracias a las vacunas
contra el 19 sólo en ventas de estas
vacunas facer ingreso más de 21 mil
millones de euros a fecha de 21 de
septiembre de 2021 bayón tec también
ingresó unos 13.300 millones
aproximadamente moderna más de 9 mil
millones es decir son unas cifras
incluso en los casos de astrazéneca de
johnson johnson que se quedan un poco
atrás muy significativas recordemos
también que una pauta completa de fitero
de moderna cuesta alrededor veinte euros
eso hace que haya países que estén
dependiendo de las donaciones o de la
voluntad internacional de la solidaridad
para poder vacunar a sus poblaciones un
ejemplo centroamérica una de las
regiones de nuestro continente donde va
un poco todavía esa
inmunización global y vemos que en estos
tres países por ejemplo aproximadamente
el 40 por ciento de las dosis que se han
inoculado hasta el momento han sido
gracias a las donaciones del mecanismo
internacional del kóvacs marc y le pido
que se quede conmigo para hablar sobre
este tema con nuestra segunda invitada
al día por supuesto
[Música]
con nuestra segunda mitad del día donde
como estábamos conversando con más
romeros a la vamos a hablar de córdoba
que es la nueva vacuna contra el commit
1919 diseñada en eeuu pero libre de
patentes le doy la bienvenida a maría
elena botox y decana asociada de la
escuela nacional de medicina tropical
profesor además de pediatría y co
directora del centro para el desarrollo
de vacunas de texas childrens hospital
gracias por estar con nosotros o maría
elena en directo américa de france 24 le
damos la bienvenida a marc y yo en esta
sección cómo funciona esta vacuna acorde
bucks y como fuese inquietud de crear la
maria elena sí bueno buenas tardes
gracias por tenerme en sus programas
bueno nosotros hemos estado trabajando
hace más de 10 años en desarrollar
vacunas basadas en proteínas
recombinantes para coronavirus como sars
y mercy obviamente ahora para el la comi
e ingeniería e hicimos una ingeniería
genética de esta proteína en levaduras
que es un proceso de producción muy
parecido a cómo se hace la vacuna de la
hepatitis b y decidimos como usted
mencionó no patentar nuestros conceptos
de ingeniería de clonaje para poder
publicarlo abiertamente y así compartir
un poco la receta con quien quiera
replicar nuestro proceso pero también
trabajar con estas compañías
manufacturas de manufactura como
biológico y en la india- para poder ver
cómo desarrollarla con ellos y a
acelerar un poco este proceso y que
ellos puedan no solo producirlas a
grandes escalas pero después hacer los
estudios adecuados para recibir sus
aprobaciones
buenos días quería preguntarle también
los datos por ahora que tenemos son con
30.000 con 3.000 personas que es una
cifra un poco inferior
significativamente inferior a otros
estudios que se han hecho con otras
vacunas esos datos son suficientes para
que otros países las puedan puedan
aprobar su uso la o&m se la pueda
integrar dentro del mecanismo kóvacs o
todavía falta investigar mire hay que
ponerlo en el contexto de cuando se
empezaron a hacer esos estudios y cómo
estaba la pandemia en ese momento o sea
no es lo mismo hacer estudios cuando ya
la población está probablemente
infectada o acullá es ya tiene
anticuerpos presentes entonces lo que se
hace es que te busca hacer estudios que
se llaman de
puente inmunológico no necesariamente
son estudios de placebo de control de
placebo entonces lo que ellos hicieron
en la india fue un estudio basado en la
comparación o evaluar la superioridad
inmunológica del corb evax comparada con
comisión que es la vacuna de astrazéneca
producida en la india
mediante obviamente calcule acciones
estadísticas de la cantidad de
anticuerpos neutralizantes y la
activación inmunológica celular se
determina que tan superior igual o
superior es dicha vacuna y de ahí se
sacan estos porcentajes con estos
correlatos inmunológicos para determinar
si que es más de 80% contra la de la
neutralización del virus delta o beta en
este caso entonces lo que se pretende es
que eventualmente lo que se hacen son
estos estudios probablemente
considerados fase 4 que son post después
de la introducción como usted sabe ya
está autorizada en la india pero
mientras uno hace estas introducciones
se sigue evaluando su seguridad y su
efectividad pero la buena noticia es que
segura es efectiva se puede producir en
miles de millones de dosis y podemos
replicar su proceso porque ahora estamos
transfiriendo la tecnología también a
otros manufacturadores que van a
producir
vacunas muy similares al core de backs
en otros lugares del mundo
maría elena para cuando fue el momento
que ustedes decidieron hacerla libre de
patentes y por qué
bueno nosotros tenemos 20 años de
trabajar en desarrollo de vacunas para
enfermedades tropicales como chagas como
parásitos intestinales entonces nuestra
misión y visión siempre ha sido de
colonizar
producir nuestras tecnologías con acceso
global para que otras las reproduzcan y
que se hagan estas vacunas y se
desarrollen en los países donde se
necesitan entonces ese concepto ya
existía dentro de nuestro centro y
cuando obviamente vemos que en un caso
de emergencia es aún más urgente que
esto sea pues
la posibilidad pues decidimos también
mantener ese mismo concepto entonces
desde el principio decidimos que será la
mejor manera de poder contribuir en
nuestro pequeño centro es haciendo
estudios que puedan ser compartidos con
otros
justamente usted decía que se puede
producir en millones y millones de dosis
y que se puede compartir esta
información pero imaginamos que se
necesita también la tecnología la
infraestructura necesaria para poder
producir está qué tan fácil va a ser en
donde más se va a poder producir este
tipo de vacunas
bueno la buena noticia es que hay un
ecosistema de infraestructura
porque todos los que pueden producir
vacunas de hepatitis b las vacuna de
pertussis alrededor del mundo ya tienen
ese conocimiento y esa infraestructura
por ejemplo el biológico y ellos ya son
manufacturadores calificados para este
tipo de vacunas entonces no tuvieron que
invertir en crear nuevas fábricas o en
obviamente capacitar nuevo personal ya
para lo mejor hasta tenían los insumos y
los equipos disponibles estamos haciendo
lo mismo con biopharma que se está en
indonesia que ellos también son otros de
los productores de hepatitis b y
bangladesh tiene capacidad latinoamérica
tiene capacidad ciertamente brasiles
tiene capacidad de hacer este tipo de
vacunas entonces la verdad es que
andábamos buscando quien pudiera
producir esta vacuna porque ya tienen
esa infraestructura
eso también acelera el tiempo pero
también evita ese aprendizaje como usted
dice de que tienen que invertir mucho en
capacitar nueva gente o construir nuevas
fábricas mars y yo estoy disfrutando de
esta conversación no me quiero imaginar
usted pero maría elena vuelvo a
preguntarle le quiero una duda que
tenemos acá en nuestra redacción en este
estudio de sacar el dinero para
desarrollar esta vacuna recibieron ayuda
pública digamos el gobierno de eeuu
nuestro programa de coronavirus como
mencioné me empezó hace 10 años y si
empezó con un fondo del instituto
nacional de la salud era un brunch que
recibimos para poder desarrollar la
vacuna de sars y la vacuna de merz para
esta vacuna de la cob y nos dieron un
pequeño fondo para poder hacer de nuevo
ese puente para traducir de nuestro
conocimiento de sars a asarse 2 pero
después la verdad es que fue una
compilación de muchos fondos donados por
fundaciones por individuos por entidades
que a lo mejor hasta no tienen nada que
ver con investigación y desarrollo por
ejemplo en texas nos dieron fondos una
compañía de producción de vodka que se
llama titos vodka y muchas otras
fundaciones y entonces privilegiados que
la verdad es que fue más que todo una
especie de mini crowdfunding porque la
verdad es que no fuimos beneficiarios de
muchos de los otros
mecanismos de obtener fondos federales
o globales a mí me parece algo
sorprendente en una especie de falta de
interés también en poder producir una
vacuna libre de patentes eso le quería
preguntar también si ustedes han sufrido
un poco se han notado está esta falta de
compromiso también de las instituciones
para que desarrollen su vacuna habido
muchísimo compromiso muchísima
información sobre facer sobre moderna y
en cambio sobre córdoba les pues estamos
apenas empezando a hablar de eso
entonces a qué atribuye este tipo este
tipo de problemas bueno es cierto um a
veces tiene la solución en frente de la
nariz no teníamos ya estas plataformas
de producción convencionales que tal vez
es cierto no se les dio la atención
necesaria porque si a lo mejor necesitan
un poquito más de tiempo para producir
para hacer estas ingenierías pero como
usted ve una vez que ya están
desarrolladas tienen mucha más capacidad
de no solo producción producción en
grandes escalas producción diversificada
en varias regiones del mundo y cuando yo
creo que el error fue que cuando vieron
que esta pandemia se estaba convirtiendo
global
pues tal vez perdieron un poco esa
perspectiva de que solamente con estas
nuevas tecnologías por más que se
quisiera no iba a haber producción
suficiente para poder obviamente vacunar
a toda la población alrededor del mundo
y hemos visto como eso pues ha permitido
este virus siempre está por delante y
mutando a medida de que no nos da abasto
de llegar con las vacunas cuando ya
tenemos otra mutante en frente entonces
por eso es que es la urgencia de ahora
darle esa importancia a estas nuevas
generaciones de vacuna nosotros no somos
los únicos hay otros que están tratando
de desarrollar estas vacunas basadas en
proteínas y ver cómo se pueden avanzar
mariah no le quiero preguntar así y si
confía en que su vacuna puede entonces
contribuir a cerrar esta brecha de
desigualdad en la inmunización global
contra el cob y 19 para ya finalmente
poder hablar en un futuro no muy lejano
ojalá así sea del fin de esta pandemia
de kobe 19 es que tiene que suceder para
que esto pueda ser así y maría elena
bueno primero tenemos que obviamente
acelerar un poco el hecho de que vaya
lógico y que pueda no solo distribuir su
vacuna en la india sino que también
pueda llegar a países fuera de la india
ellos ya están trabajando con las
entidades globales y probablemente con
los países para poder hacer estas
evaluaciones para ver si puede ser
autorizada en otros lugares al mismo
tiempo e incentivar a la gente de que si
tienen la opción de vacunarse pues que
lo hagan y yo creo que esto también va a
dar un poco más de confianza a aquellas
personas que prefieren una vacuna basada
en una tecnología convencional y lo más
importante es que esta vacuna también va
a ser muy pronto evaluada para su
aprobación para las edades pediátricas y
también para su uso como refuerzo que
eso también va a ser muy importante
porque puede ser también distribuida y
usada en aquellos individuos que también
ha usado han usado otras vacunas
anteriormente doctora pues ha sido un
placer conversar con porque realmente
tendremos que seguir con mucho detalle
cómo avanza korver bucks en el mundo que
logros se consiguen y también que nuevos
datos podemos recabar
muchas gracias un gusto haber conversado
con usted de verdad ha sido un placer
tenerla como invitada estábamos
conversando con maría elena votarse
decana social de la escuela nacional de
medicina tropical profesora de pediatría
y doctora en el centro para el
desarrollo de vacunas de texas childrens
hospital gracias doctora nuevamente por
estar con nosotros en directo américa
gracias mar también por acompañarnos en
esta sección del invitado del día
especial teniendo a esta invitada de
lujo ustedes continúen con nosotros
seguimos en directo américa
[Música]